hi I'm Melissa VOR and I do voice
impressions for example this is Kristen
wig about to go
skydiving I changed my
mind I'm I'm scared I'm scared I'll get
stuck on a cloud and then I'll have to
become an
angel
thanks this is Sandra Bullock if were to
knock over a bunch of dominoes just
pretend they're here in the
room no no no that's
it she always does that in movies and
this is Lady Gaga if she gave birth to a
baby and a star is
[Laughter]
born
Miss Gaga A Star is
Born and this is Melissa vior giving a
TED Talk hi I'm Melissa vior and I do
voice
impressions a little bit about me born
and raised in Los Angeles California to
a Mexican American Family a middle child
okay I was very shy didn't do the best
in school but I was very observant maybe
a little creepy and I realized I had
this superpower of doing voice
impressions when I was 12 years old and
it all began with the pop singers at
that time okay Britney Spears all you
people look at me like I'm a little
girl I know
spooky and hot I should do that all the
time
huh I sang a lot of Shakita back then
just there's a she wolf in the closet
and I was kind of wolf-like singing that
13 you know hairy puberty
days I looked up to Gwen Stefani in high
school I loved Gwen Stefani from no
doubt and I wanted to look like her so I
shaved my eyebrows real thin to copy her
like in the return of Saturn days that
that Gwen and I thought oh my friends at
school must think I look just like Gwen
Stefani I probably looked more like it
the clown it was spooky thin just I kind
of always KN and end up looking like
like I loved making my friends laugh at
school with my voices and I suddenly
wasn't so shy anymore I felt like oh
this is why I'm here this is my purpose
to bring joy and laughs and I suddenly
got obsessed with Saturday Night Live at
15 years old and I was so determined I
was like I'm going to become a comedian
and I'm going to get on the cast of
Saturday Night Live so right after high
school I graduate I go straight to
signing up for open mic shows in
Hollywood my parents went straight to
woring for their
daughter now I went to Junior College
for them you know I went for like a
quarter or a semester I don't know I
wasn't there long enough to find
out but thankfully I got amazing
opportunities pretty early on in my
career because I think it was rare to
see a female voice impressionist at
comedy clubs and a cute
one
but I got the opportunity to be on
America's Got Talent season 6 in 2011
not going to lie I killed it okay 90
seconds I did a bunch of Impressions
just Barbara Walters I did um Natalie
Portman from the Black
Swan I did a Sarah
Silverman Wanda syes uh I did molus and
Christina
Ager
from that exposure being on that show I
was able to quit my part-time job and
become a headlining comedian around the
country for clubs and colleges now
that's amazing if you've been doing
standup for a while but I only had 10
minutes and suddenly I had to do an hour
at comedy club so I bombed a lot I cried
in a lot of hotels around the
country but I noticed something as I was
on the road working on jokes and
Performing I noticed that everyone was
laughing at all the impression bits but
every time I try to talk about myself
and my life and my family it didn't get
laughs it was starting to bug me people
will come up to me after shows and they
would go oh I love your Owen Wilson
impression he's so funny and I'd say
thanks but inside I'd be like wait do
they only like me for my Owen Wilson
impression W that really bumps me out
yeah so at that point I became
determined again I was like no I'm going
to write about myself I want to find my
own voice among the voices that I do
because I think it's important and it's
special and I think it's the best
feeling to connect as your true self
with other
people and you know thankfully I did
find a voice yeah a funny sounding one
but a voice and I like making fun of
things in life it just makes life a
little easier to handle I like making
fun of my energy
it's not sexy you feel
it my energy is a lot like a proud
dads no wonder relationships don't work
out cuz every time I go on a date I
check out the dude first thing and I go
man look at
you man you look good is that a new
jacket you look really sharp my
boy here's 20 bucks don't tell your mom
go
ahead
I like talking about how I'm Mexican you
know and I don't look at a lot of people
don't believe me all my life people
would say oh you're Mexican you don't
look Mexican and I get so apologetic I'm
like oh I'm so sorry I forgot my somo oh
man did I not roll my RS enough sorry
and I just have to salsa
away I know exterior you wouldn't
believe it but just know that
inside a lot of pinatas in here I bleed
tapao you know I'm I I don't speak
Spanish I I was a lazy kid second
generation Mexican I didn't work on it I
know shame on me or as you would say in
Spanish I don't
[Applause]
know I have been working on my Spanish
though because there's a lot of
relatives of mine that only speak in
Spanish and I think back when I would
hang out with my great grandma my aita
know I would just nod and smile wave at
her how rude she didn't mind she was
just star at me lovingly you
know i' be like hey aita how are
you
Mela Chita
Bonita thanks you're Bonita
too and then she'd start talking crap
about me in Spanish and Melisa I
see I know I'm Loca you too huh no me
no
okaya what the tone changed what are you
two saying over here I don't like this
why are you sad now
what is that boyfriend I don't want one
right now I'm
free fair
enough see I like imitating my family
and talking about him because that'll
never get old that's always a part of me
celebrities I don't even know them you
know but this means so much to me I like
imitating my mom she's a funny character
when I'm driving my car and she's in the
passenger seat she's a backseat driver
she comments on my driving and she knows
it pisses me off so she Whispers
everything about my driving which is
like that's worse everything sounds so
dirty to my innocent ears I'm driving
she's in the passenger seat holding on
to that rail you know she's pressing it
I didn't know there was a brake pedal on
that side cuz she is pressing it she's
just slow
down ah you're going too
fast ah we're not in a
rush ah oh my
back oh there's a spot right there right
there right there right there
a you missed
it ew
nasty now after N9 years in my journey I
did get the the chance to audition for
Saturday Night Live in 2016 and I get
cast on the show
yeah it was so beautiful to be on the
show and magical it felt like I entered
I mean my dream it was real it was it
was it was
beautiful and it amplifi being on SNL
Amplified everything I ever wanted
especially for doing voices now I left
SNL after six seasons on the show just
recently because one I I wasn't strong
enough anymore to handle the pressure of
the show two I wasn't having fun anymore
looking up celebrities and three there
was something inside me inside meliss
that was saying there's more to discover
about myself there's more talents
there's more things to learn to expand
on so now I'm in a funny position cuz I
did the go evil
laugh no but it is a funny position I'm
in because that was the goal I worked
for it since 15 and it's so like now
like what do I do has anyone here
reached a life goal and still have years
left
it's there was even there was one day
recently I Googled what the hell do
Olympians do after they go to the
Olympics just CU I want to know other
people that feel this way I did find out
on Google Olympians become teachers and
mentors and I thought well if that I
don't want to do that
the thing I noticed within this the six
years of being on
SNL there was something the best stuff
that I did were pieces where I was was
doing my Impressions but I was also very
much being Melissa so as I go forth in
my journey I got to remember to always
share the gifts that I have of doing
voices and also make sure I could be
vulnerable and be
myself so something I love to share in
my standup shows is how I struggle with
low self-esteem and I constantly have to
tell myself positive talk and
affirmations now I don't use my voice no
I sound too sarcastic I don't believe
me if I say I'm good at what I do I'm
funny I don't no thankfully I have a
Dolly Parton
impression so I say my affirmations as
Dolly works way better just I'm good at
what I do I work
hard I work I work 9 to5 what a way to
make a living more like 10 minutes cuz
I'm doing a tick
to so I hope the lesson or thing you
leave with is that I hope you could put
your masks down your personas and be
your true true self because man it
rocks maybe learn a dolly impression so
you could look in the mirror and say I
am brave I am beautiful or better yet
learn your Melissa impression so you can
look in the mirror and say man look at
you he you're
cool muchas gracias thank
you